ciao a tutti io sono gesù quello di
nazareth
se non mi conoscete questo il mio drom
my life sono nato a betlemme in
palestina
mia mamma si chiamava maria è una bella
donna israelita molto molto brava
talmente brava che un giorno un angelo
di nome gabriele la va a trovare le dice
occhio che mossa incinta il bambino lo
chiamerà gesù e sarà il figlio di dio
lei non fa in tempo neanche a
preparargli un caffè che gabriele se ne
vola via
il problema è che mia mamma era
fidanzata con un uomo giuseppe giuseppe
amava e rispettava tantissimo maria
talmente tanto che non aveva mai fatto
l'amore con lei
ecco perché faceva il falegname questa
era una battuta sulla masturbazione
chiedo scusa
e infatti quando maria dice a giuseppe
che aspetta un bambino
lui a svariate domande ma alla fine
accetta di essere il patrigno di un
bambino nato da una donna vergine messa
incinta da una divinità è una storia
talmente assurda che solo mel gibson
poteva farci un film sopra o george
lucas quel bambino speciale sono io da
piccolo non ho mai dato problemi ai miei
genitori a scuola ero un bambino modello
non ci sono mai andata per questo ora si
discute tanto che io ci sia ma un giorno
mentre ero seduto su una panchina
meditare vengo morsicato da un moscerino
della frutta radioattivo è la mia vita
cambia iniziò a sviluppare poteri
sovrumani posso guarire i malati posso
riportare in vita i morti o salvato
maria maddalena dalla lapidazione ma poi
ho scoperto che era la nipote di mubarak
c'è stata quella volta dove c'erano
migliaia di persone affamate e non
avevano abbastanza cibo
allora o moltiplicato pane e pesce per
tutti però mi sono accorto solo dopo di
aver dato pesce avariato agli arabi
spero che non se la siano presa ho il
potere di camminare sull'acqua e di
trasformarla in vino se non vi fa schifo
il retrogusto di piedi o persino il
potere di essere realmente esistito ma
senza che nessuno abbia mezzi
informazioni per provarlo ma come
insegna mark zuckerberg non puoi farti
500 milioni di fedeli senza qualche
traditore è infatti giungla vivendo le
guardie per 30 miseri pezzi d'argento
giuda infame per te solo pane le guardie
mi catturano ponzio pilato fa un
sondaggio gesù contro barabba mi tortura
noemi crocifiggono in sala mensa
gentilmente siccome il bricco era chiuso
mi chiedono di accavallare le gambe
perché hanno solo tre chiodi e poi muoio
stanza spoglia ma confortevole letto un
po duro è solo un asciugamano lercio per
il viso ma tutto sommato me lo sto
godendo questo weekend lungo ma era
tutto uno scherzo nel io gabbati tre
giorni dopo tornò in vita e sono più
famoso di prima
benvenuti lulù revisione del lazio con
karim usa e ce l'abbiamo fatta e visto
che non è fallito subito più o meno come
va come state mai visto che ci siamo
rivisti non è neanche passato troppo
tempo
immagino vi starete chiedendo come sono
andati i commenti delle pisodio 0 siamo
partiti col botto e per rispondere ad
alcune delle vostre domande
sì la tazza e vota no il microfono non
funziona è finto
tralasciando le puttanate di cosa
parleremo oggi me oggi parleremo di gesù
ciò che siamo arrivati leggermente
lunghi per la pasqua ma chi se ne frega
noi parliamo in generale per questo
argomento l'intenzione di scomodare
lenny bruce praticamente l'inventore del
concetto moderno di stand up comedy
peraltro ha inventato la stand up comedy
senza sapere che fosse stand up comedy
non è che fosse subito palese per tutti
quanti è quello dice cosa interessante
che fa ridere
resta in piedi ma qualcuno
fortunatamente ci ha fatto caso è il
quello lì dice cose interessanti e fa
ridere
essa in piedi e stand up comedy fu
comunque voglio scomodare lenny bruce
perché le persone morte oltre ad essere
sempre le migliori perché in vita sono
sempre state tranquillissime hanno
sempre ragione
per questo hitler probabilmente ancora
vivo da qualche parte in quella famosa
isola segreta con elvis simona ventura
che mi serve sta praticamente diventato
un punto di riferimento in ogni puntata
hitler hitler hitler
a sto punto prima o poi gli chiedo di
intervistarlo e facciamo prima
soprattutto per parlare del mazzo di
carte da gioco di hitler che esiste per
davvero è gli chiederei come come si
vince lì ma dicevo di meghni bruce e io
voglio scomodare il suo monologo sulla
repressione della parola e lo faccio
perché è un concetto che si presta
perfettamente per qualsiasi cosa
e tra l'altro detto repressioni voi
avete pensato ad hitler non c'è via di
scampo
allora che cosa ha detto c'è qualche
lurido il micro questa sera io so che ce
n'è uno perché lo vedo lavorare la
giunta non vediamo
eccola due muri di [ __ ] e fra quei due
metri c'è un giudeo userei praticamente
lenny lo chiamo così perché ormai siamo
in team in sosteneva che la ripetizione
ossessiva di una parola togliesse potere
alla parola stessa ripetere tante volte
[ __ ] come ha fatto lui ha tolto potere
a quella specifica parola e ha cessato
l'imbarazzo in sala potrebbe funzionare
anche con la parola [ __ ] ripetere
tante volte [ __ ] elimina la presa che
questa parola sugli altri perché alla
fine di tutto diventerebbe soltanto un
suono e non più in concetto ripetere
tante volte [ __ ] attenua all'astio con
il quale la parola viene detta e ci
hanno provato tantissimo su instagram è
ma non ha funzionato per ora dirvi tutto
questo perché perché un concetto simile
è applicabile alla pasqua ma il punto è
che ogni anno a pasqua gesù risorse
no nessun uomo di colore ha ucciso gesù
quindi riponete i forconi da tastiera
che non ce n'è bisogno fate conto che un
comune mortale come david copperfield a
las vegas fa il suo show ogni giorno uno
alle 18 e uno alle 21 vi sembra giusto
che gesù ne faccia solo uno all'anno e
abbia più pubblico di lui mi ricorda
qualcuno su youtube che fa una roba ogni
morte di papa è già più pubblico degli
altri ma questa ripetizione forzata
della pasqua da anni anni anni ne
depotenzia al miracolo che poi che sia
successo per davvero no non sono qui per
discutere delle vostre inutili credenze
anche perché io sono del leone queste
cose non le facciamo è vero che è
accaduto una volta sola ma la ricorrenza
del fatto non aiuta a consolidare la
fede non aiuta a ricordare diventa solo
un a vinovo è già passato un danno se
bastasse una sola giornata di ricordo
per essere da quel giorno in poi più
buoni allora saremo migliori di quanto
non crediamo
auguri ben tornato finalmente vedo che
ti sei modernizzato mi piacevano i capi
ricordi
era un complimento beh da ma come fa
come se non contasse qualcosa al bar
come sta
ma sì tutto normale come al solito ma
sei sicuro ce la faccia no no niente
mentre non ho nulla non ho aspettati
fortuna cosa
a calzini antiscivolo mi mancavano di
fallout
grazie ma come non ti piacciono no vabbè
hanno ben capito però se devi avere sta
faccia se c'è qualcosa che non va di
melo ma dimmi tu siamo nel 2016 se non è
ancora capito in una giocata full auto
due l'hanno fatto spoiler no imbecille e
che ormai la pasqua armi ma è una festa
del cazzo cosa festeggia a fare ma non è
vero per me è importante fare il salto
ogni anno ogni anno la risurrezione mi
riporta in vita e sai cosa serve a un
cazzo sai che mi festeggia più ormai gli
anziani e quelli che mi ringraziano di
non essere andati a scuola una volta
bruciavano degli idoli mio onore
poi sono passati ai libri ti rendi conto
adesso invece mi regalano le uova decine
d'anni fa almeno mi lasciavano le
galline tra qualche anno che punta
arriviamo a lasciarli direttamente le
sorprese adesso dimmi cosa ho fatto di
miracoloso negli ultimi anni hai fatto
piangere madonnine hai fatto camminare
gente con in spalla enormi statue da
migliaia di chili per chilometri e
chilometri dalla gente ti romina spesso
quando fa sesso però beh in realtà non
tanto telepiù nome di tuo padre giuseppe
no è quello biologico il cui prima era
tutto diverso c'erano rispetto diverso
la gente veniva temi a chiedere la
redenzione adesso un casino nessuno va
in chiesa nessuno va più a confessarsi
per portarli in chiesa ha bisogno
le offerte ci sia fare la tombola perché
se non la gente non ci vede più ameni
segrete
oddio pasta basta mica che cazzo è stato
zitto e credo che fanno crocifisso si
sottovaluti troppo tu fai ancora
moltissimo in alcune culture
ci sono paesi in cui tutti i giorni
nominano e pregano te e tuo padre
ma stai scherzando il fatto che tu sia
qui oggi a raccontarmi queste cose dopo
migliaia di anni vuol dire qualcosa
tu potresti cambiare la vita del mondo
intero se solo lo volesse quindi fatti
crescere due [ __ ] santi e inizierà
ge porca [ __ ] quindi anche tu credi
beh dai almeno fra qualche mese natale
allora parliamoci chiaro noi non
crediamo più in nulla
sinceramente siamo la generazione che ha
perso la spiritualità il credo
chiamatelo come volete
per quanto mi riguarda però non è una
questione di fede e che non ho un cazzo
voglia durante il periodo scolastico tra
la prima e la terza media sono andato
all'oratorio quando dovevamo fare la
preghierina il dom suonava questa
campanella per ragionarci tutti in
chiesa quello è stato il mio primo
rapporto con dio nascosto spiaccicato
dietro la porta da calcetto perché non
avevo voglia di andare è lui che me lo
immaginavo incazzato nero dall'alto dei
cieli che mi guardava dicendo hulk rosso
fi
perché è perché non avevo un cazzo
voglia ha 27 anni io così come
moltissime altre persone
non abbiamo bisogno di credere a meno
che non si parli di hicks files non ho
bisogno di credere quindi oggi mi
rivolgo a voi portavoce
dell'illustrissimo ea lei papà francesco
aggiorniamo le divinità per esempio
quante volte la frase roberto baggio è
un dio oppure non lo so frasi come la
cheesecake e divina sono usciti dalle
nostre bocche non sarebbe l'ora di
aggiornare il catalogo per me in questi
ultimi mesi
la cosa che si avvicina di più a un dio
e just eat questo che sto per dire
sembrerà una pubblicità pagata ma non è
così anzi se volete approfittarne e lo
spazio pubblicitario è ancora libero
quindi gestite quell'applicazione che
racchiude tutti i ristoranti pizzerie
kebabari della tua zona che consegnano
ad un c
e come sappiamo tutti il cibo e la
migliore cura per qualsiasi male ti
senti morire perché la tua ragazza che
ha lasciato dicendoti che non sei
abbastanza uomo e tu sai benissimo che
lei ha ragione chi in ginocchi davanti
al cellulare e preghi chiudi gli occhi e
ti immagini una barca di sushi misto dal
tuo ristorante giapponese gestito da
cinesi preferito e in men che non si
dica appare un omino che ti dà tutto
quello che hai chiesto abiti di una
villa isolata nel mondo
non importa abiti al loro piano senza
ascensore non importa quell'omino farà
sempre più davanti alla tua porta e se
paghi con paypal non gli devi manco dare
la mancia sto programma la tua religione
fa queste cose qui
me lo vedo proprio maometto che sale 9
rampe di scale col kebab da una parte la
montagna dall'altra
ora vi do una statistica vera al 100 per
cento esattamente vero persone in tutto
il mondo si sono fatte esplodere in nome
di justin
anche perché alzare le braccia e urlare
sono 7 euro e 50 in onda lo stesso
effetto
e sapete perché perché just eat unisce
tutte le nazionalità sotto lo stesso
tempo il cibo vedrai marocchini insieme
a giapponesi arabi insieme ad americani
uno spuntino insieme alla pizza e totò
al massimo gesù può farti il solito
piattino di paolo e pesce vino rosso e
tutti sanno che col pesce ci si abbina
il vino bianco visto le divinità che ci
portiamo avanti per anni sbagliano anche
le cose più semplici già state esiste
per le persone
da come me che non hanno un cazzo voglia
di alzare il culo che sono magre ma con
la pancia che la loro attività fisica e
sollevare ipotesi just eat è la risposta
al mio procrastinare incessantemente da
27 anni
justin è la mia religione
amen
cazzo se ho voglia di oliva scolare in
questo momento
finalmente
possiamo rilassare perché abbiamo finito
anche questa puntata sulla pasqua avete
visto che è come halloween è identica da
lui però con più maria maddalena io vi
ringrazio per aver seguito questa
puntata per essere stati con noi anche
questa sera e io adoro fare questo gesto
di mettere a posto i fogli anche se in
realtà sono soltanto tre